dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with corrosion a failure I
apologize for the delays during last
week I always put out notifications
about such events on Twitter and
Facebook make sure to follow us there so
you fellow scholars know about these
well in advance and i have to say during
this time i really miss you and making
videos so much this video is a quick
update on what has happened since and
i'd also like to assure you that the
next two minute papers episode is
already in the works and is going to
arrive soon very soon patreon is a
platform where you can support your
favorite creators with monthly recurring
tips and get cool perks in return we
have quite a few supporters who are
really passionate about the show and
during the making of the last few
episodes we have encountered severe
hardware issues there were freezes
random restarts blue screens of death
constantly and the computer was just too
unstable to record and edit two minute
papers the technicians checked it out
and found that quite a few parts would
have to be replaced and I figured that
this would be a great time to replace
this old configuration so we have
ordered the new two minute papers rig
and the entire purchase happened with
the help of you our patreon supporters
we were able to replace it effortlessly
which is just amazing words fail me to
describe how grateful I am for your
generous support and I'm still stunned
by this it is just unfathomable to me
that I am just sitting here in a room
with a microphone having way too much
fun with research papers and many of you
enjoy this series enough to support it
and it had come to this you fellow
scholars make two minute papers happen
thanks so much I try to squeeze in a bit
of footage of the new rig and
transparency above all will post the
configuration in the video description
box for the more curious minds out there
what I can say at this point is that
this new rig renders videos three times
as quickly as the previous one and even
though these are just short videos the
rendering times for something in Full HD
and 60 frames per second are
surprisingly long even when run on the
graphical card
well not anymore so one more time thank
you so much for supporting the series
this is absolutely amazing it really is
this was a quick update video the next
episode is coming soon and I try my very
best so we can be back at our regular
schedule of two videos per week lots of
spectacular works are on our list stay
tuned oh and by the way we have fellow
scholars watching from all around the
world and in the meantime some of them
have started translating our episodes to
German Portuguese Spanish and Italian
for some reason I cannot see the names
of the kind people who took their time
to contribute so I'd like to kindly
thank you for your work it makes two
minute papers accessible to even more
people which is amazing thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and I'll see you next time